By Ayurvedic doctor tested all my supplements via electrodermal testing, how does this compare
to conhesiology?
Well, it's just different.
So electrodermal test is if you put your hand on a cradle and you test a supplement and
it can test positive or negative for you and it's just a different way to test with conhesiology.
With my conhesiology I lock into your body, then lock into cancer and we're tested against cancer, we're not testing the supplements just, you know, in random.
So it's tested against your cancer.
So that's the difference on how we do conhesiology.
That being said, there's all sorts of different practitioners that do conhesiology that.
It's just personally, I wouldn't trust, so I mean, it isn't art form that you have to trust the person doing it.
I would have the 35 supplements that I'm taking, he said my body only responded well to four.
And I should only take those four.
So what should I do? I really don't know what to do since I purchased all these supplements already.
Again, I'm not ever telling anybody here that you got to do it my way or, you know, you got to make that decision of what you got to do.
You, you trusted me to test you and it came back the testing that came back.
And you're going to somebody else to test you too, then you got to just decide what you want to do.
So I can't tell you, no, you need to do this, you know, your body knows if you need to make that decision.
If that practitioner is being kind of, you know, arrogant and say, this is all you should be doing.
You should be doing well, then you got to make that decision.
I can't, I'm not going to get into an argument between practitioner.
So you decide what you want to do.